New York's governor says the limousine
that crash and killed 20 people should
have been parked for good investigators
say the limos driver Scott listen nikkia
who died in Saturday's crash did not
have a proper license federal records
also show prestige limousines the
company that owns the limo has been
cited for 22 violations in the last 24
months DeMarco Morgan is at the crash
scene in scary about 25 miles west of
Albany with new information from
investigators
DeMarco good morning we had a good
morning you were out here with us so you
know just exactly how close I am to the
crash site but we've been pushed back a
little further because of the
investigation but police are telling us
that the limo that was involved in that
crash failed an inspection sometime last
month the NTSB says the Ford Excursion
that was carrying 18 people was
originally a traditional SUV that was
stretched the board is now examining
when and how the vehicle was converted
and what caused this tragedy driver to
limo did not have the appropriate
license to operate that vehicle
investigators said Monday the limousine
carrying a group of young people headed
for a birthday celebration never should
have been on the road what about the
vehicle was that outdated was it
properly fit that company and that
vehicle have been under scrutiny of
d-o-t in the past that's all I can say
about that prestige limousine owned the
vehicle
according to federal records in
September 3 prestige vehicles failed
inspections and were cited for multiple
violations including no or defective
emergency exits and malfunctioning
brakes those safety issues had been
addressed incorrect
attorney Lee Kinlan represents prestige
limousine not all infractions are major
a lot of these things were minor and
more fixed but if they were minor and in
fixed how did we get to where we are
today
with 20 people dead including the driver
well I don't think that these
infractions were
what led to the tragedy police say
prestigious 2001 Ford Excursion limo was
traveling Southwest on State Route 30 in
Schoharie Saturday when it drove through
a stop sign at an intersection there are
no signs the limo tried to brake as it
barreled into a parking lot outside a
country store there it struck and killed
two pedestrians and slammed into an
unoccupied Toyota Highlander before
landing in the woods all 18 people
inside were killed New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo the owner of the company
had no business putting a failed vehicle
on the road prestige limo is owned by
local residents ahead Hussein according
to court and public records a man by the
same name was caught in Albany in 2001
trying to help someone obtain a driver's
license illegally he pleaded guilty in
2003 and became an FBI informant records
show he testified in several
high-profile terror cases a photo taken
from surveillance videotape shows him in
2004 as an informant holding an inert
rocket launcher during a sting operation
ken 'ln says his client is currently out
of the country we did have a phone
conversation earlier this afternoon What
did he say he wanted me to again do
whatever I could to express to the
families and the victims his sorrow
the FBI isn't commenting on whether
who's saying it was an informant and
authorities seized four vehicles from
prestige including that limo and police
are also saying that the victims who
were inside the limousine they actually
rented a bus from a different company
but the bus broke down they hire
prestige at the very last minute Nora oh
that detail oh my goodness DeMarco thank
you